the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
let's go now to storyboard 36 starting
with panel a regulation of metabolism so
far in 507 we have looked at metabolic
pathways from the perspective of the
cell in organelles within the cell using
physiological scenarios I tried to show
you how pathways within the cell respond
to a change in the environment for
example by running away from a stressor
such as a dog or dealing with the
problems of starvation or diabetes we
have looked a little bit at the ways
that individual steps and pathways are
regulated with not however looked at the
ways that individual pathways and
individual organs coordinate the
respective activities in order to
accommodate the needs of the entire
organism coordinated pathway networking
is the focus of this lecture let's turn
to panel B I'm going to start out by
talking a little bit about the seven
pathways that we've studied in detail in
507 and look at how they're regulated as
I've said before typically pathways are
regulated at their rate determining
steps that is the step at which you'll
find an enzyme that has a large free
energy change associated with the
conversion of substrates to products in
the first pathway we studied glycolysis
there are three irreversible steps
specifically the glucokinase slash
hexokinase step secondly the
phosphofructokinase one-step and thirdly
the last step pyruvate kinase these are
all sites of pathway regulation our
second pathway the tricarboxylic acid
cycle or Krebs cycle was regulated at
every step at which NADH is produced
that is citrate dehydrogenase alpha
ketoglutarate dehydrogenase and malate
dehydrogenase while pyruvate
dehydrogenase is not formally part of
the TCA cycle I'll point out here
that it is also regulated by NADH in all
four cases NADH feedback inhibits the
enzymes that produce it under conditions
of excessive TCA cycle activity you'll
find that NADH levels will drop and
accordingly NAD+ levels will increase
the reduction in NADH will result in
activation of the pathway in other words
the disappearance of NADH results in the
uninhibited a our third pathway
gluconeogenesis is regulated at the
pyruvate carboxylase step at the
fructose 1 6 bisphosphate a step and at
the glycogen synthase / glycogen
phosphorylase steps we're going to be
looking at this pathway in some detail
in a little while our fourth pathway
fatty acid catabolism is regulated at
the cat or carnitine acyl transferase
step which is inhibited by malonyl
coenzyme a melon Eelco a is one of the
key precursors for fatty acid
biosynthesis it makes sense that the
concentration of malonyl coenzyme a if
high would inhibit the uptake of fatty
acids into the mitochondrial matrix keep
in mind that uptake into the matrix is
the job of cat one shutting down cat one
by the high concentration of Millenial
co a prevents entry of fatty acids into
the mitochondrial matrix where they
otherwise would be subjected to beta
oxidation by turning off cat one malonyl
coenzyme a prevents the futile cycle of
simultaneous fatty acid degradation and
biosynthesis the fifth pathway is fatty
acid biosynthesis acetyl co a
carboxylase or acc is the enzyme that
makes millennial coenzyme a out of its
precursor acetyl coenzyme a this enzyme
acc is activated by insulin as we've
seen before
insulin detects the fed state in the
organism hence following a meal insulin
levels rise and that's the signal that
tells the cells of the body to take up
nutrients that's just one example after
a meal glucose levels will rise in the
butt insulin will be released and drive
the glucose into the cell the cell will
then activate pathways by which the blue
is converted to acetyl co a then the
acetyl co a will be converted into fatty
acids and then ultimately into
triacylglycerols for energy storage
our sixth regulated pathway is the
pentose phosphate pathway glucose
6-phosphate dehydrogenase is the first
step in the pathway and as we often see
an early or committed step is where
regulation happens one of the products
of the pentose phosphate pathway is
NADPH if the cell has used a lot of
NADPH for example for biosynthesis its
levels will drop coordinate Li there
will be an increase in nadp+ in the case
of glucose 6-phosphate dehydrogenase we
find that nadp+
which is the product of excessive
reductive biosynthesis as well as other
activities such as combating oxidative
stress activates the dehydrogenase in
order to enable the synthesis of
additional NADPH in order to sustain
biosynthesis the last pathway the
seventh is electron transport and
oxidative phosphorylation this is our
most robust pathway for the production
of ATP when there's a lot of demand for
ATP ADP levels will rise in the cell and
it's ultimately the level of ADP that
regulates electron transport and
oxidative phosphorylation more about
that in a few minutes let's now look at
panel si organs communicate with one
another by the nervous system of course
but also by hormones
small molecules that are secreted by one
organ that will have an effect at one or
more organs distal to the first organ
changes in our environment are detected
by the brain with input from our sensory
organs our internal organs such as the
liver pancreas kidneys adrenal glands
and muscles will detect signals either
independently of the brain or after an
instruction set is received from the
brain the resulting signal network will
allow the entire organism to be able to
adapt to the new environment be it one
of stress for example being chased by a
dog or one oh for example hunger we'll
talk later about the adrenal glands
which are going to respond to
signals that come in from sensory organs
though tell our muscles to start running
and to tell the liver to start to
provide the muscles with the glucose
they need in order to sustain running
later we'll be looking in some detail at
the adrenal produced hormone epinephrine
also called adrenaline adrenaline will
have a profound impact both in the
muscles and in the liver to allow these
organs to do the respective jobs the
pancreas is a very important organ in
that it provides exocrine functions that
help with it with digestion and
endocrine functions that enable us to
regulate or balance fuel metabolism the
alpha cells of the pancreas produce
glucagon the alpha cells sense hunger
they secrete glucagon into the blood
which travels to organs that represent
our fuel depots and fuel from those
depots for example fatty acids and
glucose will then be supplied to other
tissues of the body that are in need of
nutrition the beta cells of the pancreas
since what we call the fed state and
they produce insulin insulin instructs
the various organs of the body to take
up fuel in the wake of us having eaten a
meal now let's look at panel D there are
three general paradigms by which
pathways are regulated the three
hormones that I've just mentioned
typically will cause the activation of a
kinase that will phosphorylate a target
protein resulting in either increased or
decreased activity of that protein we
call this hormonal or bar properly
covalent control because there will be a
covalent modification of a protein that
will be responsible for pathway
regulation the second major paradigm by
which pathways are controlled is
allosteric regulation earlier in 507
joanne stubby showed us how hemoglobin
the molecule that carries oxygen in the
blood is controlled by
bisphosphoglycerate and protons which
act as allosteric effectors similarly
other small molecule effectors will
control the major pathways of metabolism
we're going to be looking at phosphoric
Co kinase 1 is our prime example the
third strategy of regulation is what I
call acceptor control this is the way
that electron transport and oxidative
phosphorylation are regulated
to the right side of panel D is an
abbreviated metabolic pathway that I'm
going to use to describe each of these
three paradigms at the upper left is a
box that contains glycogen synthase and
glycogen phosphorylase earlier in 507 I
told you how phosphorylation of a
specific serine residue on glycogen
phosphorylase results in a dramatic
increase in the activity of that enzyme
a little later we'll see that covalent
modification again by serine
phosphorylation of glycogen synthase
results in a decrease in activity of
that enzyme
hence covalent modification of these two
proteins enables in one case activation
of the enzyme and in the other case
inhibition of the enzyme the reciprocal
control prevents futile cycling now
let's look at the box in the center of
this abbreviated metabolic pathway the
glycolytic enzyme PF k1
phosphofructokinase one converts
fructose 6-phosphate to fructose 1 6
bisphosphate we're going to see that a
small molecule derivative of fructose
6-phosphate specifically fructose 2 6
bisphosphate will act as a powerful
allosteric stimulator of pfk 1 I'll also
point out that a.m. P adenosine
monophosphate will also stimulate this
enzyme I'll also point out here that pfk
one is a tetra mer often times as Joanne
taught us proteins that are multimers
are the ones that are subject to
allosteric regulation our third paradigm
of regulation is acceptor control shown
in the box at the bottom of panel D
during periods of intense physical
activity ATP is consumed and converted
to ATP and NADH is converted to nad plus
rising levels of ADP in the
mitochondrial matrix activate the proton
translocating ATP synthase as more
protons flow through the synthase more
ATP is made
they call this acceptor control because
the regulatory molecule is adp which is
the quote-unquote acceptor of phosphate
in the synthesis of ATP because we
covered acceptor control in some detail
in the lecture on on electron transport
and oxidative
to phosphorylation I'm going to leave
that topic for now and focus on covalent
control and allosteric control let's
turn now to storyboard 37 starting with
panel a with regard to the paradigm of
covalent control I'm going to focus on
the pair of enzymes glycogen synthase
and glycogen phosphorylase which
reciprocally regulate glycogen synthesis
and glycogenolysis let's consider a
scenario in which there's some kind of
stressor the muscles have to be
activated in order to be able to deal
with the stress and the liver has to be
able to provide the resources to the
muscles that will allow the muscles to
continue intense physical activity now
let's look at panel B in our scenario
you've just seen something frightening
your brain then sends an electrical
signal to the adrenal glands which then
send a chemical signal specifically
adrenaline to the liver and to the
muscles at the top part of this response
scenario both the liver and muscles are
going to be responding in a very similar
way however at the bottom part of the
response scenario the liver and muscles
are going to be activating very
different pathways specifically we're
going to see that muscles will strongly
activate glycolytic pathways in order to
enable the production of ATP to keep the
muscles running the liver by contrast is
going to be activating pathways that are
more like those of gluconeogenesis that
is spilling out fuel from the liver to
provide the muscles with the energy rich
resources that it needs to keep us
running away from our stressor
adrenaline or epinephrine travels from
the adrenal glands through the blood it
takes only a second or two for this to
happen it's received by the liver and
the muscles at the beta-adrenergic
receptor the blood concentration of
epinephrine is very low something of the
order of 10 to the minus 10 molar at
this point there's going to be a very
substantial signal amplification as we
move ahead keep in mind for later that
the initial triggering signal is in the
10 to the minus 10 molar range the
arrival of epinephrine at the receptor
results in structural changes in the
transmembrane domain of
beta-adrenergic receptor the signal is
received by a hetero trimeric g-protein
shown as the circle with alpha beta and
gamma subunits this g-protein in its
inactive state has a bound molecule of
GDP that is guanosine diphosphate upon
receipt of the signal from the beta
adrenergic receptor the hetero trimeric
g-protein ejects the beta and gamma
subunits and the gdp molecule which is
non killed covalently bound is released
the gdp is replaced by a GTP guanosine
triphosphate this replacement results in
the formation of the alpha subunit with
a non covalently bound GTP this is the
active form of the enzyme it
translocates along the inner surface of
the membrane until it encounters AC or
ad neill cyclase the GTP bound
g-protein activates adenyl cyclase the
activated AC dynamically starts
converting ATP which is very abundant in
the cell into cyclic a MP we call cyclic
a MP the second messenger in our
scenario the first messenger is
epinephrine which interacted with the
beta adrenergic receptor the second
messenger of cyclic a MP which is
produced by the activation of adenyl
cyclase which is asymmetrically
associated with the inner surface of the
cell's membrane let's turn now to panel
C and the upper left of panel C you'll
see a box this box depicts the chemical
mechanism leading to the production of
cyclic GMP let's now look at the main
part of the panel in a very short period
of time a matter of seconds the
concentration of cyclic AMP e within the
cell goes from about 1 micromolar up to
about 5 micro molar so the presence of
epinephrine at the 10 to the minus 10
molar concentration outside the cell
results in a perturbation of cyclic A&P
concentrations inside the cell
bringing cyclic a.m. P concentration to
about 10 to the minus 6 molar this is a
very substantial increase in signal
which an engineer would call gain the
increasing cyclic
a MP concentration is going to activate
a kinase cascade in the initial kinase
that's going to be activated called
protein kinase a or PKA which is
represented symbolically as a C with a
circle around it in my drawing in its
inactive state protein kinase a is in a
complex involving two molecules of
itself and two molecules of a regulatory
protein which I've indicated as an R in
the middle of a circle cyclic a and P
forms a tight complex with r this
basically causes our to dissociate from
the active subunit C that is the
catalytic portion of protein kinase a
the catalytic portion of protein kinase
a is now free to act as a kinase to
phosphorylate the next kinase in the
Cascade which is called spk or synthase
phosphorylase kinase a serine residue on
SP k is phosphorylated and that event
converts this kinase into its active
form I'll also point out that one of the
subunits the Delta subunit of SP K is
the calcium binding protein calmodulin
which gives a second level of regulation
to this enzyme specifically this enzyme
is regulated not only by the
concentration of cyclic GMP but also by
the levels of calcium within the cell
the activated SP K or synthase
phosphorylase kinase is now going to
phosphorylate to other proteins glycogen
phosphorylase and glycogen synthase as I
mentioned earlier phosphorylation of
glycogen phosphorylase results in the
enzyme becoming more active that is it
starts breaking down glycogen by
phosphor alysus to produce glucose
1-phosphate which will then be available
for further metabolic processing in the
muscle glucose 1-phosphate will be
converted by phosphoglucomutase into
glucose 6-phosphate which will then be a
substrate to initiate glycolysis with
the ultimate generation of lots of ATP
for the muscle in the liver
phosphoglucomutase will convert glucose
1-phosphate into glucose 6-phosphate but
in this case gluconeogenesis will be
activated glucose-6-phosphatase will
remove the phosphate from glucose
6-phosphate converting it to glue
the glucose will then be secreted from
the liver go out into the blood and then
go to the muscle to help the muscle
carry out glycolysis now let's look at
the other target of spk synthase
phosphorylase kinase specifically
glycogen synthase in this case glycogen
synthase phosphorylation results in a
less active protein and hence glycogen
synthesis will cease this makes sense
because the cell under stress would not
want to be making glycogen it wants to
be using energy and not storing fuel
let's step back and look at the big
picture at this point the interaction of
a hormone resulted in the covalent
modification of proteins one of those
phosphorylated proteins glycogen
phosphorylase triggered glycogen
breakdown phosphorylation of a second
protein glycogen synthase turned it off
turning off glycogen synthase helped us
avoid the otherwise futile simultaneous
synthesis and breakdown of glycogen so
overall this is an example of a hormone
causing covalent modification of
proteins in such a way that it altered
the activity of those proteins in a
manner that made sense given the
physiological challenges to the organism
next let's turn to storyboard 38 panel a
our next regulatory paradigm will be the
use of allosteric effectors to regulate
a pathway as before I'm going to use the
physiological scenario of stress but in
this case I'm going to show how stress
will cause the production of small
molecule allosteric effectors that will
activate glycolysis in the muscle and
activate gluconeogenesis in the liver
our focal point is going to be pfk one
phosphofructokinase one of glycolysis of
central importance is going to be a
small molecule fructose 2 6 bisphosphate
which we'll see is going to be a very
powerful allosteric stimulant of pfk 1
fructose 2 6 bisphosphate is made by the
enzyme PF k2 phosphofructokinase 2 let's
start out by looking at the very short
biochemical pathway shown in panel a
we seek glucose converted by hexokinase
or glucokinase to glucose 6-phosphate
and then some equilibrium steps up until
we get fructose 6-phosphate ordinarily
we think of fructose 6-phosphate as
continuing in the glycolytic pathway but
let's not think of it that way right now
the chemical structure of fructose
6-phosphate is shown slightly to the
right note that fructose 6-phosphate has
a phosphate on the six hydroxyl group
and that the one hydroxyl functionality
has only a hydrogen this is the Alpha
anamur of fructose as evidenced by the
fact that the hydroxyl group on carbon
to the anomeric position is down or
under the furanose ring with a little
bit of electron pushing you can change
the stereochemistry at the two carbon
such that the hydroxyl group would be up
or in the beta configuration in the beta
configuration the hydroxy methyl group
of fructose 6-phosphate which includes
its one carbon would be down the beta
and alpha an immersive fructose
6-phosphate are in equilibrium that is
they both exist at the same time the
kinase fossil Forktail kinase two
catches the beta anomer of fructose
6-phosphate
and phosphorylates it producing the
molecule at the lower right of this
panel that's the actual structure of
fructose 2 6 bisphosphate this is the
molecule that's going to serve as the
allosteric effector of the glycolysis
pathway the PF k 2 or
phosphofructokinase two enzyme is shown
to the left it's a complex enzyme having
lots of different functionalities the
hatched circle within the larger circle
at the top represents the
phosphofructokinase domain which
converts fructose 6-phosphate to
fructose to 6 bisphosphate that is the
structure at the lower right the hatch
domain at the bottom is the fructose
bisphosphate a's domain this is an
unusual enzyme in the top domain it acts
as a kinase in the bottom domain acts as
a phosphatase PF k2 has two hydroxylated
amino acids 100 about 3 o'clock has
drawn and the other at about 6 o'clock
when the hydroxyl group at the bottom is
present as a pure unmodified hydroxyl
group the protein acts as a kinase when
the six o'clock domain is phosphorylated
the enzyme acts as a phosphatase protein
kinase a or PKA from the previous
storyboard where we talked about
hormonal regulation is the kinase that
phosphorylates the hydroxyl group at six
o'clock on the protein as we'll see
later the hydroxyl group at three
o'clock is targeted by a kinase called a
MP kinase in the muscle before we go on
I want you to look carefully at the
structure of fructose 2 6 bisphosphate
at the bottom right of panel a compare
that structure with the structure of
fructose 1 6 bisphosphate at the right
in panel B if you squint and look at
these two molecules you'll see that they
look remarkably alike in both cases the
phosphate group is above the plane of
the furanose sugar however in the case
of fructose 2 6 bisphosphate the
phosphate is on the two carbon whereas
with fructose 1 6 bisphosphate the
phosphate is on the 1 carbon the way
these molecules look will become
important in a few minutes now let's
take a look at the pathway of shown in
panel B panel b reflects the liver in
its normal that is non stress state so
this is just the liver doing everyday
liver business glucokinase of the liver
is converting glucose to glucose
6-phosphate the Alpha anamur of fructose
6-phosphate is produced most of the
fructose 6-phosphate is converted to
fructose 1 6 bisphosphate in the liver
cell at this time there's probably some
low level of glycolytic activity going
on however because of natural anamur is
a ssin some of the alpha fructose
6-phosphate is converted to its beta
anamur phosphofructokinase 2 or pfk 2 is
shown to the lower left and it's active
note that neither of its hydroxyl groups
at this point are phosphorylated and
it's kinase
we'll be converting the beta
fructose-6-phosphate anamur to its
phosphorylated form that is beta
fructose - 6 bisphosphate which has the
structure shown at the bottom right of
the previous panel fructose - 6
bisphosphate is a positive allosteric
effector of phosphofructokinase 1 so it
facilitates the glycolytic pathway that
is enabling net flux from left to right
in the pathway as shown in addition to
stimulating glycolysis fructose to 6
bisphosphate strongly inhibits
gluconeogenesis it does this by binding
at the active site of fructose 1 6
bisphosphate a's the gluconeogenic
enzyme clogging up the active site and
thus disabling the gluconeogenic pathway
the reason that it's such a good
inhibitor of gluconeogenesis stems from
an examination once again of the
structures of fructose 2 6 bisphosphate
in the bottom right of the previous
panel and fructose 1 6 bisphosphate
shown to the right on this panel keep in
mind that fructose 1 6 bisphosphate
while it's the product in glycolysis is
the substrate for the gluconeogenic
reaction if the active site of the
fructose 1 6 bisphosphate ace is clogged
by fructose 2 6 bisphosphate then it's
not going to be able to process the
fructose 1 6 bisphosphate in the
gluconeogenesis
gluconeogenesis is strongly inhibited
all of the above shows us that fructose
2 6 bisphosphate is really important it
stimulates the forward direction in the
liver that is causing glycolysis to have
a net flux from left to right and in
addition it strongly inhibits the back
reaction that is the reaction in the
gluconeogenic direction turn at this
point to panel C now let's ramp up the
scenario and think about a situation in
which you're being chased by a dog you
want to be able to generate glucose in
the liver and then export that glucose
to the muscles so the
you can run away from your phone this is
a situation in which you would like to
have your liver stop doing glycolysis
you want the liver to strongly turn to
gluconeogenesis in order to manufacture
glucose for the muscle at this point
refer back to the storyboard that dealt
with covalent control where protein
kinase a was activated recall the part
of the lecture when I talked about
covalent control and we were talking
about the glycogen phosphorylase step in
the liver in the liver we generated
first glucose one phosphate and then
glucose 6-phosphate
and then the phosphate was lopped off
the glucose 6-phosphate to produce
glucose that went out into the blood in
the present case we're looking at a step
that's further down in the
gluconeogenesis pathway specifically we
want to activate the fructose 1 6
bisphosphate a's in order to push even
more carbohydrate toward the production
of glucose so in panel C we see stress
inducing the cyclic ANP cascade that
results in activation of protein kinase
a and protein kinase a is going to
phosphorylate the southern most that is
six o'clock domain on the PF k2 or
phosphofructokinase to protein as i
indicated earlier phosphorylation of the
six o'clock domain results in conversion
of phosphofructokinase to from a kinase
into a phosphatase the phosphatase
produced from PF k2 will act upon the
pool of fructose 2 6 bisphosphate and
convert that pool to fructose
6-phosphate that is the 2 phosphate will
be locked off of the fructose 2 6
bisphosphate molecule by doing this
biochemistry in the liver we've done two
things first we destroyed the fructose 2
6 bisphosphate pool hence this molecule
is no longer available to act as an
allosteric stimulator of PF k1 secondly
removing fructose 2 6 bisphosphate from
the pool has resulted in removal of the
active site inhibitor of fructose 1 6
bisphosphate ace this enzyme therefore
becomes active and is able to push the
net flux of carbon
from right to left in the direction of
gluconeogenesis producing glucose that
will then spill out into the blood
please turn now to panel D we just saw
that the liver post dress produces
glucose now we're going to take a look
at the muscle which of course is going
to be using that glucose in response to
the stress State the muscle is going to
activate an enzyme called the a MP
dependent protein kinase or a MP kinase
also known as a and piqué and piqué
activates metabolic pathways that
generate ATP the three o'clock
phosphorylated pfk to proves to be an
exceptionally competent enzyme for
converting fructose 6-phosphate
into fructose to 6 bisphosphate this
increases further the concentration of
fructose to 6 bisphosphate in the muscle
cytoplasmic pool and keep in mind that
fructose to 6 bisphosphate itself is a
powerful allosteric stimulator of
glycolysis by its effect on PF k1 so in
the muscle cell we're able to achieve
extraordinarily high concentrations of
fructose to 6 bisphosphate thus favoring
glycolysis let's turn now to storyboard
39 let's start with panel a the way that
a MP kinase stimulates glycolysis in the
muscle post stress is illustrated in
this abbreviated metabolic pathway
starting at the lower left the stressor
has created the cyclic a MP cascade that
activates a and P kinase a and P kinase
phosphorylates the three o'clock domain
on pfk 2 converting it to its
phosphorylated derivative that shows
powerful kinase activity to convert
fructose 6-phosphate
into fructose to 6 bisphosphate this
enhanced pool of fructose to 6
bisphosphate will now act as a powerful
allosteric stimulator of PF k1 to favor
glycolysis i want to point out that
muscles do not do gluconeogenesis only
the liver and Riedl cortex do this
pathway so muscles do not have fructose
1 6 bisphosphate ace the gluconeogenic
Enza
accordingly in muscles we don't have to
worry about gluconeogenesis being turned
on to some extent and thus dampening the
glycolytic effect in the muscle that's
needed in order for the muscle to
generate the ATP needed to outrun your
foe on this panel we also see that there
are several other effectors that
influence the activity of pfk 1 1 is
citrate another is ATP another one is a
MP or adenosine monophosphate I want to
say a couple of words about a MP in this
regard let's look at panel B a MP is not
as powerful an allosteric effector on
pfk 1 as is fructose 2 6 bisphosphate
but we know a lot about its activity as
an allosteric effector because it's been
studied quite thoroughly pfk one is a
tetra mer and its activity is regulated
by cooperativity this graph shows the
activity of PF k1 as a function of the
concentration of one of its substrates
fructose 6-phosphate
when there's no ATP present which is not
a realistic situation you see the
regulatory pattern following that of a
rectangular hyperbola that's scenario a
scenario B shows what would happen to
the activity of the enzyme when ATP is
present at a concentration of about 1
millimolar
which is quite realistic and what you
see is suppressed activity when the
heterotopic allosteric effector a and P
is added you see the curve shift to the
left that is you get enhanced activity
at a given substrate concentration my
guess is that fructose 2 6 bisphosphate
would push the curb even further to the
left let's now look at panel C I think
it's useful to use a and P to help us
construct a model for what fructose 2 6
bisphosphate might be doing as an
allosteric stimulator of the pfk one
enzyme the equilibrium diagram that I've
drawn shows the relationship between the
relaxed that is more active state of the
pfk one tetramer and the tents that is
more inactive state of the enzyme when
ATP is abundant within a cell it binds
more strongly to the tent state and
hence ATP in activates pfk
one this makes sense because if ATP is
abundant you do not want to be doing
glycolysis to make even more ATP however
when the ATP pool of a cell is
challenged by doing heavy work or
biosynthesis the AAP is going to bind
more tightly to the our state of PF k1
and that's going to help convert the
enzyme into its more active state that's
a little snapshot of how a small
molecule in this case a MP or perhaps
fructose to 6 bisphosphate can
dramatically regulate the activity of an
enzyme at a specific step in metabolism